j'ai mauvaise grâce à a commencé mon
propos
sans faire résonance avec ce qui vient
d'être dit parce qu'il ya john dit oui
le grand philosophe américain que vous
connaissez peut-être pas mais je vous
encourage à le lire qui disait qu'il ne
peut pas y avoir de démocratie s'il n'y
a pas la démocratie dans l'école et dans
l'atelier et dans l'entreprise et je
crois que c'est fondamental nous sommes
au coeur de ce que nous ne savons pas
faire c'est à dire apprendre à
travailler apprendre à travailler avec
les autres après on est en relation avec
les autres et c'est l'école ne l'a
jamais appris elle nous a appris à
compter
à lire elle nous a appris plein de
choses merveilleuses mais peut être en
relation fondamentalement avec les
autres pas être dans cette résonance pas
savoir être dans le collaboratif et
aujourd'hui c'est un des enjeux
essentiels pour les entreprises
je vais commencer par une une mesure qui
étaient prises en france depuis
maintenant le 2 juillet de cette année
qui correspond aux enfants justement on
interdit la fessée aux enfants
j'ai envie de commencer par ça parce que
c'est l'élément central de mon
intervention sur justement être en
posture de l'intelligence relationnelle
pour faire collégialité managériale
c'est compliqué tout ça je vais essayer
d'expliquer pendant les quinze minutes
courte donc je vais me seriez sur juste
le management de proximité et je vais
vous parler d'où je suis senior je suis
prof je suis chercheur c'est à dire que
j'ai une équipe et j'ai des étudiants
qui travaillent sur l'un sur la
démocratie d'entreprise l'autre sur
l'intelligence l'intelligence
relationnelle la troisième sur
l'expérimentation mais aussi
j'interviens dans des entreprises une
plutôt grosse bien plus de 40 mille
salariés puis l'autre une association de
1000 salariés qui a grossi fortement qui
travaillent
auprès de personnes âgées ehpad en
particulier et puis déjà en fin de vie
ce qui est je vais vous l'expliquer un
peu plus compliqué dans le relationnel
justement alors pourquoi je vous parle
de la fessée interdite
la bonne raison simple c'est que
aujourd'hui un enfant c'est un être
humain qui a des droits et la relation
d'autorité qu'il y avait
traditionnellement ne peut plus
fonctionner sur cette forme là on peut
plus effectivement battre un enfant
bon vous avez tous moins de 30 ans donc
vous ai pas connu les martin est allé
martin et c'est quelque chose qui
fonctionnaient bien alors il faut que je
dis bien parce qu'en fait généralement
les enfants en coupe et une lanière par
semaine et quand on était deux comme
chez moi ma soeur et moi dans un coupé
chacun 1
donc effectivement ma grand-mère chaque
fois se demander pourquoi est-ce qu
effectivement à la fin il n'y avait plus
que deux c'est à se demander ce qui se
passait mais parce qu'en fait nous on
était on n'avait que la seule solution
c'était se taire et ont subi c'est
effectivement une violence mais qui
correspondait je dirais à ce qu est l
enfant au niveau étymologique enfance
in fine ce celui qui n'a pas la parole
et bien cette relation d'autorité
c'est cette relation là que nous avons
aujourd'hui encore dans l'entreprise
c'est encore cela qui fonctionne en
entreprise et que la question qui se
pose c'est de quelle manière on remet en
question cette autorité qui est une
autorité du chef
je vous rappelle qu'il y avait le chef
de famille est le chef d'entreprise
puissent toujours le chef le chef c'est
quoi c'est la tête la tête et puis les
jambes et la tête
c'est d'abord et surtout le celui qui
décide
celui qui dirige et celui qui à la fin
va sanctionner s'il y a s'il y avait une
question qui ne correspond à une plutôt
une action qui ne correspond pas ce qui
a été décidé par ce chef est bien la
question aujourd'hui dans les
organisations
ça ne peut plus fonctionner de cette
façon ça ne peut plus fonctionner alors
pourquoi ça peut fonctionner c'est les
gilets jaunes ont été l'expression la
presse en a parlé d'ailleurs en disant
que cela crise de gilet jaune
correspondait à management à la
française or pas tout à fait à la
française parce qu'en allemagne je sais
pas si vous avez vu avec le le lieu dit
el gheït le diesel gates est aussi le
management par la peur
je vais m'en expliquer mais en france la
question de la relation d'autorité du
chef
ça veut dire d'abord du command and
control
c'est ce mode là et c'est ce mode là
aujourd'hui qui est en crise le mode de
tales rien ou neotel rien un soyons plus
jeunes et faisons du delà du management
participatif donc on va être né ou le t
il rien avec des méthodes de justement
participative enfin une fille née la
décision et c'est vous inquiétez pas
c'est celle qui aura été décidé au plus
haut niveau
la question aujourd'hui dans beaucoup
d'entreprises
l'allemagne par exemple regarder le
désert gates
c'est ça a été le les ingénieurs qui
pour faire plaisir aux responsables ou
dirigeants ont truqué pas simplement les
données ils ont truqué les les
différentes
technologie qu'il fallait inclure pour
valider et valoriser la le la façon dont
le moteur était produisent et de là je
vais y arriver
produisez du de la pollution et donc ils
ont réussi à faire croire que
effectivement le moteur était de bon
niveau en termes d'environnement
je dirais qu'il ya deux choses il ya
d'un côté le travail prescrit et d'autre
le côté le travail réel et que les
organisations fonctionnent sur ce mode
là c'est à dire qu'on veut faire plaisir
et donc on courbe l'échiné et puis on
toujours le pouvoir de ce chef est que
ce chef là aujourd'hui
et bien c'est cela qui est en crise
c'est ça qui est en crise
donc il faut trouver d'autres modes et
le d'autres modes ça va être sinon la
démocratie tout au moins la façon dont
effectivement d'une relation pyramidale
toujours pareil
le chef nous passons dans une relation
circulaire entre paix rhdp hier on passe
de la verticalité une certaine
horizontalité mais vous allez voir qu'il
faut quand même un minimum de
verticalité je vais vous en reparler
dans quelques instants
donc je le disais qu'il y a premièrement
dans ce pays un management une culture
fondamentalement celle du père on est
passé quand même n'oublions pas de la
loi de l'autorité paternelle à
l'autorité parentale
donc 10 170 1970 jusqu alors vos grands
parents
c'était le poteau le grand père c'était
lui qui était qui avait l'autorité qui
avait le pouvoir et progressivement on
se retrouve à 2 à devoir discuter d'être
négociées peut-être aussi décider
ensemble
après discussion ça veut dire que c'est
un changement complet dans les modes
relationnels
c'est cela aujourd'hui qui est temps
je dans les organisations et dans les
entreprises en particulier c'est
commencé effectivement à être dans des
relations
sinon d'égalité mais au moins entre
pairs dans lequel on va devoir le devoir
discuter devoir décider en semble les
américains utilisent un terme
empowerment
je ne sais pas si vous connaissez vous
êtes familier avec cette expression
elle signifie alors chez nos amis
québécois c'est extraordinaire parce que
eux ils parlent français
ils disent que c'est de l'autonomisation
ça veut dire quoi
c'est le pouvoir d'agir ensemble à
partir d'une autonomie de chacun ça
correspond à ce que certains théoriciens
de la pédagogie développe mais c'est
quelque chose qui nécessite un
apprentissage
ça nécessite d'apprendre ça nécessite je
dirais de de casser nos habitudes et
c'est ce que je constate moi dans les
entreprises dans lequel je suis en train
de travailler dans lequel mes étudiants
aujourd'hui observe on est dans la
recherche action on réfléchit puis
ensuite on insuffle je dirais des des
concepts nouveaux
première chose posture d' intelligence
relationnelle
ça veut dire que il va falloir
effectivement que nos étudiants
développent une relation avec chacun qui
est une relation d'égalité dans lequel
on n'est pas dans le jugement dans
lequel on ne cherche pas à écraser
l'autre une relation de pouvoir
ça veut dire que d'abord et surtout
cette posture d' intelligence
relationnelle
c'est une capacité soit même d'avoir
travaillé sur soi ça correspond à une
vraie volonté aujourd'hui de la plupart
de nos jeunes de nos jeunes étudiants et
de mes étudiants c'est effectivement
d'avoir
une autonomie d'avoir le plaisir de
travailler d'être responsables de ce
qu'ils font et que ça c'est quelque
chose qui nécessite d'autres formes de
relations que la forme du contrôle
systématique
je vais me faire engueuler parce que
j'ai fait une connerie voire même n'a
pas le droit à l'erreur quoi vas-y nom a
comme d'habitude tu n'as rien compris
c'est fondamentalement une autre
relation avec noah avec autrui et donc
je vous parlais des raisons alors
première chose donc je je j'allais
oublier l'élément le plus essentiel
c'est ccc je n'ai pas là mon téléphone
[Musique]
tout nos outils
tous nos outils que nous avons qui fait
qu' on est en train au moins dans dans
l'est dans l'eure on doit avoir au moins
un mail on doit avoir au moins sur
facebook je ne sais quelle photo bref on
a plein d'informations qui nous arrive
et ça c'est vraiment libératoire est
formidable c'est vrai que c'est ça nous
ouvre au monde
c'est vrai que dans l'entreprise tous
ces outils là sont des outils qui ont
permis effectivement de remettre en
question toutes ces hiérarchies qui
fonctionnait bien sûr là c'est les moins
de 40 ans par notre papier
1 le chef il envoyait une note et puis
et puis tout ça descende et descendent
et descendez aujourd'hui c'est la
transversalité
il ya un fameux livre qui s'appelle le
monde est plat the world is flat donc
effectivement l'information créée et de
la transversalité créé de
l'horizontalité et ça c'est
extraordinaire c'est en train de
remettre en question justement les mots
des rares chic dont je parlais tout à
l'heure mais il ya quand même un petit
problème le petit problème c'est que on
est de plus en plus dans de
l'information beaucoup d'informations
trop d'informations bref l'information
tu l'information
10 le dit le proverbe mais au delà de
tuer l'information c'est quand on n'a
plus le temps
c'est chronophage tout c'est tout ce
flux d'informations c'est chronophage au
détriment de quoi de la relation combien
de fois on envoie un mail à son collègue
est juste la porte à côté et on va pas
le voir parce qu'on n'a pas le temps
parce qu'effectivement la journée elle
dure même certains c'est peut-être un
peu la nuit
peut-être même c'est la soirée c'est le
week-end parce qu'effectivement il faut
faire il faut envoyer il faut répondre
quasiment en temps réel et que tout cela
est au détriment de la relation et que
la relation est bien c'est bien ce qui
nous manque
pourquoi parce que l'humain est là c'est
une question de base c'est que l'humain
est un être social et que l'humain il a
besoin d'autrui
pour se rassurer mais aussi pour être
reconnu l'humain il a besoin constamment
d'avoir ce regard de l'autre enfin
constamment ou régulièrement quand je
lis régulièrement c'est dans une
entreprise si quelqu'un dans un
dans un bureau ne va me dire bonjour un
jour à au pas ses collègues
oui pourquoi pas un deuxième jour par
contre il va saluer et saluer puis
l'avait autour non mais c'est trop
ignorée j'imagine que dans les 24 heures
dans les 48 heures il aurait une
réputation ou tout au moins on se
demande qu'est ce qui se passe parce
qu'effectivement on a besoin de tous nos
yeux tout on a besoin de se dire monde
se reconnaître la reconnaissance
réciproque
parce que je te dis bonjour mais
j'attends contrepartie comme puisse
bonjour et que c'est pas sympa ce
bonjour c'est aussi beaucoup de choses
qui sont essentiels et qui sont tiens il
va où il va pas parce que n'oubliez pas
que nous sommes tous des inconnus
d'abord inconnue pour nous mêmes mais
inconnu pour l'autre on a toujours
besoin de se rassurer toujours besoin
d'être en interaction avec l'autre et
que ça c'est une dimension centrale d'où
le fait d'avoir un certain nombre de
techniques et d'outils à développer pour
justement être en meilleure cohérence en
meilleure symbiose en meilleur résonance
avec avec autrui est aujourd'hui dans
les entreprises il faut que développer
ces on n'a pas ça développe personnel
rappelle ce analyse transactionnelle on
appelle ça bnl en axel sa co
développement on appelle ça
psychologiquement dit yves mettez tout
ce que vous voulez mais s'est développée
justement la façon dont chacun est en
résonance avec autrui pour développer
sinon l'empathie développer ces
questionnements là et ses formes là et
donc ce qui va être important c'est la
façon dont nous allons développer cette
intelligence relationnelle qui va devoir
se concrétiser sur des notions de
collégialité alors que la collégialité
c'est assez simple c'est la façon dont
dans une entreprise vous allez faire
travailler des gens ensemble discuter
des gens ensemble et qu'ils vont se
qu'ils vont décider aussi à ce nombre
d'actions et que ces notions là ça
nécessite au minimum un rôle qui
s'appelle un animateur quelqu'un de
neutre
c'est plus le manager c'est pas lui
manager ou tous installés
il s'est complètement transformé et que
ce cet animateur c'est quelqu'un qui va
permettre effectivement à ce que circule
la parole à ce que les relations entre
les personnes soit ce soit d'une façon
non agressive d'une façon de non
jugement et qui va permettre
effectivement de s'écouter mutuellement
ces centrales je pense au co
développement en particulier qui sont
des techniques tout à fait intéressante
qui nous viennent comme par hasard comme
beaucoup de ces techniques qui nous
viennent du monde anglo saxon et du
québec en particulier donc un élément
central pour tout c'est cette
collégialité managériale c'est la
capacité de développer une relation
d'égalité entre les personnes des
relations de nom pouvoir qui nécessite
un animateur qui va effectivement faire
en sorte que les réunions régulières
qu'il va y avoir
grosso modo une réunion par semaine va
permettre effectivement de pouvoir
décider discuter avec des modalités qui
peuvent être n'en parlait ce matin
j'étais dans une conférence sur le fait
qu'ils aient plus de sly par exemple sur
le fait que la réunion
elle va durer dix minutes un quart
d'heure le matin pour se réguler debout
pour justement faire en sorte que
rapidement on se dise les choses et puis
la réunion hebdomadaire où tous les dix
jours va avoir pour fonction de parler
de dossiers et le dossier sera préparé
par une personne par exemple monsieur
bezos le patron d'amazon lui il a arrêté
les arrêter les slides il fait en sorte
d'avoir un petit un document qui fait
maximum trois pages
donc chacun eut dit pendant 15 minutes
ce document est ensuite en échange et on
décide donc tout l'objectif
qu'il y a c'est de faire en sorte que la
collégialité managériale elles soient
partagées et donc c'est un fondement de
tout c'est de toutes ces évolutions
bien évidemment ça nécessite du temps ce
que je vous dis là c'est de la mise en
place dans des entreprises depuis
maintenant deux ans et demi trois ans
ils sont en train de mettre en place
progressivement ses management au
quotidien c'est management qui n'est pas
made man de décision de direction
générale
nous sommes dans une dimension du
relationnel au sens interactions entre
les personnes
voilà c'est simple c'est long ça peut
marcher si effectivement on est toujours
attentif à l'autre et on a quelqu'un
qu'on appelle ça animateur régulateurs
et qui est là pour faire en sorte de
vous cadrez est de faire en sorte de
d'éliminer toute fin d'éliminer de faire
en sorte ne plus avoir ses dimensions
d'agressivité qui est notre mode de
culture relationnel dans ce pays en
particulier et en france en particulier
voilà écoutez dernier point
dernier point c'est maintenant à vous de
le mettre en place c'est le agir sellem
poreux min
n'oubliez pas le pouvoir d'agir avec les
autres par rapport à sa propre autonomie
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]